good afternoon and welcome to today's
forum
offer perspectives on rotc of Columbia
I'm John cotesworth Dean of the School
of International and public affairs here
at Columbia and I'm delighted to see you
all here today's forum is sponsored by
the Arnold Saltzman institute of war and
peace studies and jointly sponsored with
the school itself super as you know the
question whether Columbia should again
play host to a formal Reserve Officers
Training Corps program has become the
subject of a lively debate at the
University the University Senate which
is composed of 108 elected and appointed
members representing faculty students
administrators research officers
librarians and alumni appointed a task
force to look into this question after
repeal of the military's don't ask don't
tell policy the task force conducted a
poll among the more than 11,000 students
enrolled in the five schools including
sepa whose students participated in
off-campus ROTC programs in the past
five years of that number 2252 students
registered their opinions somewhat more
than 9,000 did not and of that number
two thousand two hundred and fifty to
sixty percent or a little over thirteen
hundred and fifty indicated approval of
a return of ROTC to Colombia's campuses
and seventy-nine percent or a thousand
seven hundred and eighty approved of
Columbia allowing the participation of
Columbia students in ROTC whether on or
off campus We are fortunate to have with
us today professor James Applegate who
is a university senator and a member of
the ROTC task force and in a few moments
I'll ask him to say a few words about
the process and where we are the ROTC as
we know it today was created by an act
of congress in 1916 as the United
dates prepared to enter world war one
though earlier versions of this program
had existed on college campuses in the
United States as from as early as 18 19
until the 1960s many ROTC programs were
obligatory for all male students at the
campuses where they were located today
they are voluntary with participants
eligible for substantial scholarships at
present there are 273 Reserve Officer
Training Corps programs scattered among
the country's nearly 4,000 institutions
of higher education ROTC graduates
constitute thirty-nine percent of all
active duty officers in the US Armed
Forces they are especially conspicuous
in the Army where some fifty percent
fifty-six percent of all officers are
ROTC graduates though there is no ROTC
program located on the Columbia campus
today Columbia students are able to
participate via programs at Fordham and
st. Johns it is not clear in the
discussion so far what investment the
university would be expected to make or
would need to make in staff and
facilities if I can't if a it our TC
program were to be physically located on
the campus in my long career as a
teacher which as some of you suspect
began in the dark ages I have been
deeply impressed by the courage
integrity and idealism of two groups of
students I have taught in particular
those who have been willing to risk
their lives to defend their country and
their lives to change it for the better
that is why I am proud to report that 67
veteran and an active duty US military
personnel are pursuing degrees at Sipan
in addition to veterans of several other
countries of the armed forces of other
countries who are also studying among us
sepa staff has worked hard to preserve
the financial support our veterans
need to complete their studies we have
for example compensated for the recent
cap placed on fellowship funding through
the new GI bill by expanding the funding
sepa provides through the university's
Yellow Ribbon Program and I'm pleased to
see that there are a number of members
of the CEPA veterans organization here
in the audience this afternoon for our
discussion today we have invited four
distinguished members of the university
faculty who disagree as our
distinguished faculty often do on the
ROTC issue you will hear from sepa and
political science professor richard bets
and sociology professor alan silver who
favored the return of rotc to the
Columbia campus and from astronomy
professor David Helfand and English
professor bruce Robbins who oppose it as
they would be the first to tell you the
distribution of the disciplines they
represent is entirely random with
respect to their perspectives you should
not infer that the social sciences favor
while the humanities and Sciences oppose
ROTC I will ask each of the speakers to
summarize his views in eight to ten
minutes and ruthlessly enforce this
limit to leave ample time for questions
and answers after all has spoken so let
me begin by introducing professor
Applegate who will bring us up to date
on the process and decision making of
the university center I thank you very
much teens first my name is Jim apple
gave on the fessor of astronomy and as a
member of the task force in 2011 and it
was faculty co-chair of the Senate task
force that considered the return of ROTC
in the two during the 2004-2005 academic
year as Dean close with mentioned ROTC
came to the Columbia campus during the
1920s the program continued we was and
you probably also know the ROTC and
Columbia parted company in 1969 during
the Vietnam War the reconsideration of
rotc of Columbia began about two
thousand three as a student 11 ish
of that initiative produced a proposal
which landed in the University Senate
the task force was put together at that
time and which considered the issue in
2004-2005 there's a resolution that was
was drafted to suggested Columbia should
bring back ROTC that resolution failed
by a 53 to 10 vote and the major issue
that was raised in opposition dar OTC
was the Don't Ask Don't Tell law when
Don't Ask Don't Tell was repealed in
December the Senate was ready to
reconsider the issue the students have
been pushing it pretty much every year
since the 2005 vote and we consistently
told that they had to wait until Don't
Ask Don't Tell was repealed the task
force that was put together that has met
during the semester was based on what
was done in 2004-2005 the task force
consisted of nine members there was five
students including Scott severance from
sepa there was four faculty members we
were charged with essentially leading a
discussion of rotc to that effect there
was three town hall meetings of about
two hours two-plus hours each that were
held the transcripts of which are
available on the Senate website losing
email address set up we received about
120 emails those are publicly available
as well very task force produced a
report which is also available on the
Senate website our conclusions quickly
the most substantive conclusion that
task force reached is were rotc to
return to Columbia the conditions which
were first laid down in the Mansfield
committee in 1969 and have been
reaffirmed by every consideration of
rotc since then we are now the fourth in
the Columbia would retain academic
control over credit for courses faculty
titles in the life must be observed
other than that they did not recommend
either pro or con the issue was discover
port was presented to the University
Senate on Friday march forth should be
some discussion there there is a
resolution being drafted by the
executive committee we expect it will be
circulated fairly so
moon of discussion the next Senate
plenary is April first and we made we
will probably vote on the resolution
then although again that's not clear
there's an April 29th plenary that
serves as a fallback but that's where
they are thank you very much our first
speaker in this discussion will be
professor silver Americans generally
celebrate the idea of the citizen
soldier as expressing the Democratic
spirit but the meaning of the citizen
soldier has changed in America's three
big Wars conscription led to large
militaries that reflected the nation the
all-volunteer force which began in 1973
is imperfectly that a citizen military
but not only because it constitutes only
1% of the population compared to the
twelve percent that served in World War
two that one percent is
disproportionately drawn from the
military cluster a southern the southern
Midwest non-urban and increasingly
people from families with histories of
military service of voluntary service a
great divide is widening between
citizens who serve and others who do not
today I observe with the distance with
which most Columbia students view
ongoing Wars that's less true of
students who inhabit this building they
are not different from most of the
nation's educated and privileged
professional classes and many consider
the great Columbia uprising of 1968 as
an exemplary protest against the Vietnam
War as a faculty member I watched a
student opposition
dwindle as the personal odds are being
drafted a decreased for most with the
onset of a lottery system now many
Columbia students are not from
privileged backgrounds however many who
graduate from this and similar
institutions will have acquired a
comparative advantages with exceptions
the advantaged have little skin in the
nation's military service and little
contact with those who do it ruptures
the Republic to have a military composed
of people that you have never known
indeed of people but not known to anyone
who you know the officer corps is drawn
disproportionately from less selective
institutions and smaller colleges with a
marked military culture it is to such
places and to other regions than the
Northeast that rotc programs will were
withdrawn after Vietnam and the Cold War
they are the military feels comfortable
and more officers are recruited less
expensively in regional terms the
disparity is very large indeed they are
taken together eight southern states are
eleven point five percent of the
population but have almost a quarter of
all our RTC students New York New Jersey
Connecticut and Massachusetts have a
little over thirteen percent of the
population and only a little over three
percent of all RIT students embedded in
those states are much of the Ivy League
and other private selective institutions
American needs an officer corps exposed
to the critical edge that Columbia and
its peers offer now it's true that these
disproportion reflect a long-term
differences in regional cultures but
they are greatly exacerbated by the
military's recoil from urban
cosmopolitan
and and challenging locations and the
reciprocal a distance that that that
institutions like ours also take with
respect to the military to take but one
example of Virginia where the population
of seven and a half million has to has
12 Army ROTC programs while New York
City with a million more has to in an
ironic collaboration cosmopolitan
civilian elites actual and prospective
often feel that the good life precludes
military service which is honored at a
vicarious distance it's a civic scandal
that those with greater prospects are
egregiously underrepresented in military
service this damages the Republic
because if we can put eyes that ought to
bind a military service should be
recognized at Columbia as a distinctive
form of public service one among the
many voluntary activities that enrich
students lives and sustain a mix of
perspectives common life we've been told
that rotc with military's university
however students in ROTC programs enter
the military only after graduation they
are not subject to the Uniform Code of
Military Justice but have all the rights
and obligations of other students they
take the same courses and major in the
same subjects what does distinguish RIT
students is that their scholarships are
contractual in exchange for educational
expenses in a stipend they agree to
serve as commissioned officers are even
told that this is exploitative and that
any connection between the University
and military service is incongruous even
if service follows graduation however
this arrangement involves the exercise
of legal agency by persons with the
right and capacity to exercise that
agency and that agency deserves
spect and it is indefensible to preclude
a student's postgraduate plans in this
instance when the university does not in
any other we've been told that the
military is hierarchical and
unquestioned and unquestioning as and is
incompatible with academic values indeed
the military differs of a profoundly
from the Academy so in varying degrees
do many other settings that our students
enter after graduation the world is not
a campus for decades ago Columbia and
other private institutions effectively
borrowed ROTC in the passions of the
Vietnam War because the military
services did not accept the full faculty
control of curriculum of credits and the
faculty status these conditions still
apply and their reasserted in the report
of the Senate's task force the ROTC by
the vitalization Act of 1964 preempts
faculty control of these vital aspects
of university life however this law is
actually waived by written agreements
and customary practices the
massachusetts institute of technology
has three ROTC programs but its catalog
states that RIT subjects do not carry
academic credit at MIT see at MIT with
the sole exception of physical education
a print ins written agreement with its
affiliated ROTC program includes the
clear understanding that credit would
not be given an agreement in place and
adhered to by both parties for 37 years
at neither institution do commanding
officers have professorial appointments
we've heard passionate expressions that
the that the university must not lend
itself to imperialist and unjust wars of
course the university is institutionally
neutral with respect to public policy
but that formula does not capture the
tensions
that are intrinsic to our subject
American universities have long balanced
or research their teaching with multiple
forms of public service not all agree on
the legitimacy and and worth of each
form of public service for some the
schools of business server wicked
capitalism for others the schools of
social work of control the poor but some
the amenities are enclaves of tenured
radicals for others the considerable
space that is a fort of identity groups
and the program's associated with them
do not merit the respect in some large
part the institutions which are which
are sponsoring this very discussion
emerged in the Cold War addressing
national interest through teaching and
scholarship none of these constituencies
can properly can properly appropriate
the whole institution for its purposes
ruling out others they must live
together sometimes tensely bound by a
shared understanding that research and
teaching no matter how contested is our
common enterprise an RTC program and its
opponents can live in this kind of
comedy indeed from their present
together each may well learn something
of great value from the other thank you
we will now hear from Professor Robinson
thanks I wasn't really eager to
participate in this forum I have to say
I have other things to do but on the
morning that I agreed to participate I
read an article in the newspaper I'm
sure that many other people also read
the title is NATO helicopters kill nine
Afghan boys collecting firewood for
families so I want to speak to the
desirability of thinking about the ROTC
question
not just in terms of the sociology of
the American army not just in terms of
diversity on campus or respect for
diversity or so on sexual racial and so
on I think that we need to ask ourselves
ethical questions about US military from
a viewpoint which is larger than that of
our campus and from a viewpoint that is
larger than that of our nation we will
be told that the killing of the nine
Afghan boys well they were out gathering
firewood for their families was an
accident I personally believe it was an
accident it is the sort of accident that
is absolutely predictable if you put
American soldiers in situations like the
situation in Afghanistan it has happened
many times things like it have happened
and it will happen many times again it's
worth considering I think how normal it
seems that we do put American soldiers
in places like Afghanistan we not only
occupy countries and fight there we have
bases all around the country all around
the world I ask myself sometimes why
doesn't Brazil or Belgium or Belize have
bases all around the world why don't all
countries have bases on each other's
territory what is going on here that we
take it as natural and normal that the
United States should have its soldiers
all around the world on the territory of
other countries and would we make that
seem which really bizarre would we make
that seem more natural and normal or
less by putting ROTC
on our campus we will be told about the
killing of the nine Afghan kids
gathering fire fire wood that it's not
representative of what the United States
military does around the world I asked
myself what's representative and I'm I'm
an English professor I'm in the presence
of social scientists who know great deal
more than I do about this it's one of
the reasons I didn't really want to
participate but in for a penny in for a
pound I look it up on on the internet
you know and I say between eighteen
ninety and 1910 the US military was used
32 33 times three of those were to break
strikes in the United States three of
those were to attack Native Americans in
the United States and all the rest
without exception were invasions of
other people's countries that's batting
a thousand now what's representative
people at what point do you have to ask
ethical questions about what it means to
encourage a military that does things
like that on a regular basis in my
lifetime what have I seen I will leave
out Vietnam I am a the panel also pushed
a generational button that I won't go
into it but this is sort of where I come
from so that's fifty seven thousand
Americans killed everybody knows this a
million Vietnamese we kind of say a
million and we don't really calculate a
million that's a million people okay I'm
leaving that out in my lifetime the
United States military occupied Lebanon
in 1958 occupied panama 1958 invaded it
again in 1989 occupied occupied laos in
the Dominican Republic I leave out
support for military dictators
intervened against the rebels in
Guatemala bombed Cambodia bombed Muslims
in Lebanon and invaded Grenada that's
not all that's some of it I don't really
care whether you call this imperialism
or not I don't want to argue especially
in the company of people who are much
more expert than myself what the name of
it is it's immoral and it's illegal by
international law and people in this
country take it as natural and normal we
have a moral obligation to do everything
we can to stop people from taking it as
natural and normal when I read my little
list you're gonna have to stop me
because I'm just going to go on and on
and on yeah when I if I'm when I read
neither the list I left out the CIA
different not ROTC if I be including the
CIA I would of course have included the
overthrow of the democratically elected
president of iran in 1953 the same in
guatemala in 1954 the bay of pigs
invasion in 1961 the 1963 coup and Iraq
that brought Saddam Hussein back to
power the coup in Indonesia and 65 and
of course I and a in
Julai in 1973 so here's a hypothetical
for you and it's addressed at the idea
that i get for example from the
spectator in its editorial on the rotc
question which is basically that let's
not get ideological about this which
means let's not get Ithaca LaBeouf it
analysis where cost-benefit analysis
means we don't have to ask ethical
questions so what if it wasn't the
military we were talking about what if
it was the CIA that is an organization
that has consistently worked to
overthrow democratically elected
governments by violence would we proudly
encourage the forming and training of
CIA agents on our campus now I have no
doubt that we are actually training CIA
agents on our campus I would like to
think we are not proud of it you can
correct me if I'm wrong would we say
that it is entirely compatible with the
mission of university to train people to
overthrow democratically democratically
elected governments by violence would we
say as The Spectator has said that we
should not get ideological about this I
think it's fair I'm open to correction
to ask the kind of ethical question in
this case that would be applicable to a
South African a white South African
soldier who was enforcing apartheid a
French soldier who was enforcing the
occupation of Algeria an Israeli soldier
right now who is enforcing the
occupation of the West Bank a Russian
soldier who was occupying Afghanistan do
we really believe that there was no
relevant ethical question to be asked in
those cases and that the only thing to
ask was what's a cost-benefit analysis
of training people to do the things that
those soldiers did
I almost vowed not to bring up the Nazis
I didn't quite vow to do it i'll just
say since the nuremberg trials it seems
to me that just doing your job or just
following orders has not cut it thank
you thank you our next speaker is a
professor Benson well I was glad to see
the announcement the other day that
Harvard has re-established naval ROTC
and is considering possible arrangements
with the other two services I just
happened to be a graduate of West class
of Army ROTC at Harvard I joined as a
senior in 1969 as the program was being
terminated and responses the student
revolt of that spring and ironically
getting into rotc kept me from being
drafted that summer and kept me out of
Vietnam and enabled me to go to graduate
school but that's neither here nor there
the expulsion of rotc from a number of
elite universities at that time I think
resulted in large part from anger about
the Vietnam War and general
revolutionary sentiment on campuses
today I think the objections tend to be
somewhat different but I think a lot of
arguments are based on confusion about
what's really at issue one fundamental
misconception of my view is defining the
question in terms of military engagement
of the University as some of the recent
discussions of brandy issue military
services are nothing but subordinate
agencies of the United States government
arms of the executive and legislative
branches the armed forces are mandated
in the Constitution they're controlled
directed and deployed by the elected
leadership of the US government so if
anything the issue is larger than
military engagement its government
engagement by the University I'd leave
aside for our purposes concerned about
the academic status of rotc take for
granted that
if reestablished it would be more or
less an extracurricular activity
facilitated by the University on the
model of how it's done at MIT and I'd
leave aside the question of whether RTC
at Columbia makes economic sense for
taxpayers since the units here would
probably roll few participants
personally hire some doubts but I think
as a matter of principle if the
government is willing to reestablish a
program at Columbia but we should not
deny students the option to participate
to become public servants through the
standard organizational means that the
government is established to me there
are three logical grounds for posing
ROTC but none hold up except in terms of
principles so extreme that only radicals
would endorse them I think opposition
makes sense if you believe one of three
propositions one the United States
should not have any military at all or
two if American armed forces should
exist their middle management should not
include Columbia graduates but only
graduates and military academies and
ROTC programs of other universities or
three if armed services should exist and
Columbia Graduate should have the option
to lead them the university should not
have anything to do with facilitating
that option because the university
should not be involved in educating
personnel for institutions that
sometimes do bad things such as fight
wars many of us oppose or should just
not be involved in servicing the US
government in general on regard to the
first the proposition that American
armed forces should not exist I consider
that a perfectly respectable position
but if and only if you're consistent
pacifist and believe that the United
States should not have the capability to
wage war under any circumstances not for
the American Revolution in a 1770s not
to defeat the Confederacy and free the
slaves in the 1860s not to liberate
Europe from the Nazi
the 1940s not for anything because if
you want a military on the shelf for
something sometime you need to organize
and maintain it constantly in peacetime
you can't gin it up overnight when
something you suddenly want to use it
for it comes up many don't like the idea
of rotc because they don't like some
wars that the military is directed by
the US government to fight for example
in Iraq since 2003 or the current war in
Afghanistan I opposed the war in Iraq
too and I can tell you a non-trivial
number of generals in the Army and the
Marine Corps I didn't believe it was a
good thing to do either but for better
or worse the military don't get to pick
their Wars they fight where and when
President and Congress told them to
fight the issue in regard to rotc it
seems to me should not be the particular
policies of the United States government
at any one time but the relationship of
the University to government
institutions over time elected
representatives of the people legislated
the ROTC system as the principal
mechanism for supplying junior military
officers and I think the percentages
cited or even higher for junior officers
than for the officer corps as a whole
the issue to me is whether Colombia
should enable students who want to
participate in that standard system to
do so or to refuse them that option here
now regard to the second proposition I
mentioned if you do accept the need for
the United States to have a military
impeding Colombia graduates from serving
as officers in it that doesn't seem to
me to make sense unless you have in mind
some sort of caste system in which
certain professions in the business of
some social groups and not others in
Colombia is in the exempt cast the third
proposition as the university should not
be involved in providing services to
institutions that sometimes act in ways
that some of its disapprove of or should
not just be involved with government at
all that might make sense if you want a
radical readjustment of university
activity at
levels big chumps of chunks of Columbia
train people for professions in the
private sector whose activities are not
morally valued by all others at Columbia
as Allen suggested the short time ago
for example we have a whole business
school that staffs American capitalism
supplying leaders for corporations banks
and Wall Street firms that don't always
act in ways that we all consider good
for children and other living things
modern universities have been heavily
engaged in providing services to the
government for a long time in exchange
for large amounts of funding American
taxpayers provide research grants and
other funding not out of disinterested
love of learning for its own sake but to
develop and promote things deemed to be
in the public interest Columbia could
hypothetically stop servicing government
and give up the funds its accustomed to
getting for such services and the
university would survive it would just
survive in much smaller form would not
survive as we've come to know it there
are institutions of higher education
that have done this we're swearing
federal funding in order to maintain
morale independence from the government
although the only one I can think of at
the moment is Bob Jones University
finally one other objection I've heard
recently even though the Don't Ask Don't
Tell law has been repealed the military
will still not accept transgender people
so old grounds for opposing ROTC still
apply if that's a real reason I can only
reiterate that I think one should blame
the US government at the highest level
not the military as a subordinate agency
that implements government policy and by
the logic of the criticism about
discrimination on grounds of sexual
characteristics it seems to me one would
have to say that Columbia should not
have cooperated in training military
officers during World War two since the
services at that time were racially
segregated and I doubt that very many
people would believe that
Thank You professor helfen I'm going to
take a complementary tack to my
colleague bruise to me it seems much of
the debate including the debate here but
more of the debate in the various
publications by the Senate by the
commentary and by The Spectator fails to
distinguish between individuals and
institutions I at least certainly do not
in any way object to Columbia students
participating in ROTC but that's a very
different statement than saying I want
the university to sponsor an ROTC
program to me there's a fundamental dis
juncture between the military culture
and the university culture and between
military's mission and the university's
mission in society the abdication of
independent thought and moral reflection
and submission to authority while
serving the institution not as a person
but as an institutional member that is
represented by the military is to be
fundamentally antithetical to the free
and open inquiry that is the heart of
what a university is I would hasten to
add that both are important that one's
not necessarily better than the other
both cultures have very good reasons for
the rules under which they operate but
it doesn't make them the same many of
the problematic aspects of this debate
that I see are summarized nicely in the
in the sentence report we can begin with
the Student Survey the fact that 11.4
percent of Barnard and Columbia students
think we should have rotc on campus is
to me totally irrelevant to this debate
I hope we're not going to move to a
system of education by referendum will
end up in about the same shape that
California is financially furthermore it
seems to me highly inappropriate for the
report to characterize this quote as a
reflection of campus opinion campus
opinion the last time I looked involve
faculty members as well as students and
11.4 percent is not a reflection of
campus opinion secondly the issue of
discrimination I'm going through the
points in the report while I aboard the
blatant discrimination that the military
has practiced is practicing and may
practice somewhat less I implore equally
amination that many other institutions
that columbia regularly does business
with and consorts with practice as well
and this is not the basis of my
objection and I think it's particularly
weak to go to the suggestion that well
now now they're going to let openly gay
people serve in the military but they're
not going to let transgendered people I
mean exactly like two-year-olds serve
either that discrimination I think
that's a sort of silly argument so let's
put that one aside it seems to me that
many of the much of the discussion has
been so fused with an overweening
arrogance about the enormous value of
Columbia students the report says that
that the Columbia students will be quote
better and quote and will quote improve
the military I'm not so sure I don't
know how many people in this room have
spent any time at West Point but I have
in particular I spent a couple years
working with mathematicians at West
Point studying the curricular
innovations that they have developed
there and I can assure you the education
at West Point is far better than the
education that takes place for
undergraduates at Columbia so it's not
obvious to me the Columbia students have
some unique contribution to improving
the military the report goes on to talk
about opportunity and diversity and it
says that we could having our OTC on
campus could quote help attract more
applicants to Columbia now this is sort
of rissa ball right we have 40,000
undergraduate applicants that we're
going to reject and I guess we could
feel a little more smug if we rejected
42 thousand applicants but it doesn't
seem to me like a particularly valid
reason and as for financial
considerations if students or faculty
for that matter are concerned about our
scholarship awards then they should
spend their time protesting the early
decision program which admits nearly
fifty percent of the Columbia students
based on affluent zip codes rather than
ability and saves the financial aid that
they have paltry amounts left for the
other students I think we could do a lot
to put our own house in order
than ask the military to fund our
undergraduates says the military quote
should be seen as a valid career option
I agree the military should be seen as a
valid career option and it is a valid
career option but so should working for
Goldman Sachs be considered a valid a
career option and I would say it's sort
of on ethical grounds the former is
preferable to the latter but because
because we say Goldman Sachs is not a is
an acceptable potential career option
doesn't mean that we should give Goldman
Sachs space on campus then we should
invite Goldman Sachs partners to come
and teach courses of their design or
that we should accept students on the
grounds that Goldman Sachs will pay for
their education as long as they work for
Goldman Sachs for eight years following
graduation the only moderately good
argument I've heard is from my colleague
professor Applegate and just mentioned
is that last week Harvard invited ROTC
back to campus and since we know that we
have to follow slavishly in Harvard's
footsteps whether it's mowing down 17
acres of the inner city to expand our
campus or have corporate salaries and
our administration or Institute
unsustainable financial aid programs
because we have to do what Harvard does
you won't be surprised to find that I
find this argument somewhat less than
compelling but at least it's consistent
with Columbia's behavior over the last
different years the preamble of the
report of the Senate which deals with
history is certainly interesting but I
think it's largely irrelevant to this
question also the fact that twenty
percent of the first class served in the
French and Indian War and forty-five
percent of the class of 1861 served in
the Civil War and the Columbia manish
produced 70 officers for the civil war
that we manage to do all these things
without an ROTC program and I don't see
any reason why we couldn't continue that
in the future I find it curious that
this history of Columbia's interaction
with the military leaves out one of the
more significant interactions as far as
I'm concerned and that is the two-year
tenure of General Dwight David
Eisenhower Supreme Commander of Allied
forces in World War two as president of
this institution I'm told
faculty members who are no longer with
us that his first faculty meeting he got
up to address quote employees of the
University and a senior member of the
faculty stood up and said excuse me sir
but we are the university I think that
clash of cultures was obvious then and
it's equally obvious now both
institutions universities and military
are critical to a free society both
institutions themselves and the society
which they serve are in my view best
served by keeping them separate thank
you very much the floor is now open for
questions and comments there is a
microphone in the middle aisle would you
please if you have a question or comment
step to the microphone say your name and
give some indication of your affiliation
if you choose to do so and please keep
your comment or question brief so that
the panelists can respond
good
first so let me begin with a question to
the those who are in favor of rotc and
then I'll come back with a question with
those who oppose it I was quite
impressed actually by Professor Robins
long list of conflicts not for the
ethical reasons that he raised but for
the following if you count the Vietnam
War as three wars because actually
Vietnam Laos and Cambodia were all
involved and you add the two invasions
of Panama the occupation of Santo
Domingo in the Dominican Republic in
1965 the occupation of Grenada are
misadventure & and Somalia peacekeeping
in Bosnia and the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan and the restoration of a
democratic regime in Haiti in 1994 that
adds up to 14 wars of those 14 to which
we sent a number of students of mine and
thousands of others those who were
responsible for the decisions that's
dispatched the troops to those theaters
in five cases afterwards regretted it or
to use the words of defense secretary
gates should have had their heads
examined and in the other and in another
several perhaps too small to an illicit
'add retrospective commentary from the
decision-makers is not clear that any
issue of American national security was
actually involved the two invasions of
Panama for example or the occupation of
Grenada so my question to those who are
in favor of rotc is shouldn't we feel
more responsibility for our students
than to make it easy for them to be sent
on misadventures where they could get
terribly damaged or even killed when in
many cases if not most if
all the civilian leadership that is
dispatching the US military it can be
generally counted upon to make a mistake
well I don't have much to add to my
argument that if you don't want the
capability for the United States to wage
war any time then it makes perfect sense
to not have rotc but if you do then
that's a question of policy that you've
raised rather than a question of
maintaining institutions over time that
sometimes do things we think are wrong
and sometimes do things we think are
very important not much mention was made
of World War two and campaigns that I
think many people who found number of
the cases you mentioned mistaken at best
or important at worst would approve of
and as a matter of institutional
development and maintenance you can't
very well say you are all for one but
because of the other you don't want to
do whatever would facilitate the
the appropriate institution site I need
the difference between policies and
institutions is the main answer your
question
the responsibility is with the civilian
elite and that's a question of
citizenship both on campus and off
campus and much of the of the sentiment
against quote the military unquote is if
I'm if I may borrow a Marxist term
well forget about marks is misdirected I
don't claim for a moment professor Betts
knows a lot more about this than I do
that the military we that today military
elites don't engage in essentially
political decision-making in many
respects the old division of labor
between civilian Authority and military
the task is eroded they they permeate
each other there is a thing called the
and up in vats of great historian of the
military and military tourism said the
great danger of the militarism of the
civilians and as many people have have
noted the the war are sibling elites
have in recent decades not participated
nor have their sons and daughters
participated in military service I think
that indeed is part of the problem just
a quick note on World War two I feel as
passionately about World War two as
anybody I know but I must say that I
don't really at this stage accept the
argument that because the in the
mythology of World War two the United
States played an exemplary role that's
the mythology as well that that that
great experience somehow bears as it
were endlessly upon the case that
Professor bets and I are trying to make
that was the so-called the last a good
war I think that
there comes a time and here I agree at
least in formal terms that with Bruce
there comes a time when that shining
moment is not as relevant as it were as
well as happens is let's say 19 for and
1948 question come in yes sure I have
both a question and comment awesome lung
I'm a junior professor here at the
School of International and public
affairs so first the comment i probably
have a different perspective on the
academy in the military in that i spend
a good bit of my time working with the
military in places like Afghanistan and
Iraq I was just in Afghanistan in
January i'll be back the summer they do
a lot of things the military certainly
there are regrettable air strikes on the
other hand i spent a lot of time with
young men and women who did not return
fire when shot at for fear of harming
civilians so it's it's a broad
experience and one of the commanders i
worked with when i was there in january
was a Columbia Graduate he managed to
rise to a pretty senior rank without
having been in ROTC since he graduated I
believe in 87 so certainly a time when
ROTC was not around so I do think those
who were opposed do have a point you can
you can prosper in the military with
having without having been in ROTC on
the other hand I think he's been an
exemplary officer and I think you know
encouraging students to at least take a
look at those kind of things
particularly in the way that it would be
done here at Columbia if it resembles
how MIT does it and I've did my PhD at
MIT so I have a pretty good idea of how
they do it it is certainly a socially
good thing my question is for David you
began and ended with the position that
essentially the military and the Academy
are socially necessary useful
institutions but but somehow
antithetical yet somewhere in the middle
you asserted that West Point's education
is superior at the undergraduate level
to colombia's which seems to me to be
some sort of dissonance there how can an
institution that is orders of magnitude
more militarized that Columbia could
ever hope to be provide better education
if these two things
so antithetical thank you I guess I
should have been a little more narrow in
my comments about West Point the
education I was talking about was and
it's specifically in mathematics but in
general it is an education designed to
an end and the end is to be a superior
officer in the service of the Armed
Forces the characterization of that is
better is that it is more thoughtful
more collaborative amongst the faculty
and more effective in the classroom at
least by my observation of this
particular thing that's an institution
with the purpose and the sole purpose is
to make excellent officers and I think
it carries out that purpose extremely
well this is an institution with a
different purpose this is an institution
that is not a government institution is
not associated with the military in any
way or with any other operations and the
other independent institutions it is
essential that it is independent that's
an essential aspect of the core of the
institution and it is essential that it
provide the education for the life of
the mind and for the reflection moral
and otherwise of the students who
graduate from it so that when they go
out into society whether it's to be an
officer in the military or to work for
Goldman Sachs they have some larger
sense of where they fit into the world
and what their moral sensibilities have
to be and so while the education in
mathematics what I was talking about
particular i believe is superior at West
Point the purpose of the institutions
are fundamentally different and I want
to preserve that difference could I
intervene with the question I was one as
I was going to ask that the anti's it
seems to me that one of the strongest
arguments that's made by those who are
in favor of being our OTC back is that
there's something about a liberal arts
education that would help officers in
the US Armed Forces to deal with
circumstances that they might find in
the battlefield I had a Harvard student
who signed up for the war in afghanistan
by the time he got through training he
was
sent to Iraq and his not far from
Baghdad his captain pointed to a group
of several hundred Iraqi prisoners all
with black bags over their heads chained
to a fence out in the yard outside of
jail that had sells for maybe 10 or 12
prisoners a captain who was very
impatient to get on with his mission and
assigned this second lieutenant fresh
out of officer training school to take
care of them and he did he did two
things he did what anybody else would
have done which was to find a sergeant
who had had some experience running a
brig back home who seemed to know
something about how to manage prisoners
and then the second thing he did was to
pull up his laptop and Google the Geneva
Convention and I think those prisoners
as a result at least of the second of
those two acts which might have been
helped by having a that he received
perhaps different than he might have
received elsewhere probably saved lives
and it certainly meant that at least on
this one occasion the way in which
prisoners retreated in that conflict
conformed international norms so
shouldn't we have broadly educated
people in the Armed Forces serving his
officers in them I tend to agree with my
colleague on the Left I think there is
the argument some are good arguments
fought for our to see that I regarded
session that she a snobbery it in fact
even embarrassing I mean I'm a child of
the Big Ten I went to Michigan I I told
Atmos concen I look partly because I was
rejected for admission
to this place many decades ago you know
I don't buy this I admit I will follow
Bruce's lead and introduce the Nazis
experience from another perspective many
of the offices SS and otherwise who
could committed unspeakable atrocities
had doctorates from the best the German
universities in the most refined aspects
of culture my my argument is the other
way I think it's it's says something
wrong with some of the most advantaged
for the people in America not exposing
themselves to the same risks and service
as others very few in the Congress in
2003 who effectively rushed to to
authorize this abominable war in Iraq
had themselves served or had a child in
military service there's something very
deeply wrong with that is that an
argument for the draft or for rotc next
question well the draft issue oh we
might return those drafted show later
can i play this respond to your question
I think again you're confusing
individuals and institutions I have no
objection in fact I'm strongly in favor
of students with liberal arts education
becoming officers in the military the
question is which of the institutions be
blended yes I'm Doug Chalmers I'm
political scientist retired and I'm glad
I came right after that comment because
i think the the one issue the only issue
that i can see that to inhibit the
reintroduction of ROTC training for a
Columbia students is a question of what
the institutional form will they take I
mean I'm the the notion about Goldman
Sachs running things
was cute but it doesn't really it isn't
Goldman Sachs it's the financial
instruments and the financial
organizations of the United States or of
the world that are that we've and we do
invite those and they come in as donors
they come in as with representatives
they do all kinds of things there's an
integration of the institutions and
certainly with the government as dick
bets was talking about there's a lot of
integration of the institution but it
might be the case and this is really the
quest that I have and it's a more
general question I'm not sure who should
then who should i address it to and that
is what would they be the institutional
character of this when I went to I went
to MIT and therefore I was in the kind i
entered ieave as a freshman MIT and
therefore i had to go to rotc because
it's a land grant school and then I kept
on it because I wanted to keep out of
the Korean War as somebody else it so I
have some experience with actually in
three different universities the ROTC
program and as far as I could tell the
ROTC program was in a you know it was a
separate building over there in this was
the University of Illinois MIT and then
at boden college and it had nothing it
didn't into it wasn't a institution
built into the into the university
framework in any sense that implied
anything bad about it but it could be
and I think the only thing I hear is a
casual references the fact that well
there's an issue about whether the army
would have control over granting
professorships and that that would seem
to me to be a that would absolutely kill
the kill the
the proposal as far as I'm concerned but
I was wondering whether is there any
more sense as to what the what the
actual institutional position would be
here at Columbia University I raised
this question with Professor Alabama
have seen is in the back of the room
perhaps you can respond that yeah the
the institutional the the issues that
caused Columbia in the United States
Navy to part company in 1969 were
academic issues they involved the fact
that the Navy was teaching ROTC courses
that were accepted for Columbia degree
credit and the curriculum isn't was
under control the Navy that naval
officers were appointed as ex-officio
members of the Columbia faculty and the
two Navy was essentially control in
Columbia space these were the things
that we're addressed by the Mansfield
committee and the ansible committee sent
were concluded that if naval ROTC were
to continue at Columbia in 1969 that all
of these would have to be regularized
the United States Navy found these
conditions intolerable and the ROTC
arrangement was terminated what is not
generally known is is that the
conditions that were found intolerable
at Columbia were found workable in other
places most notably Princeton and MIT
and also Penn Cornell in some of our
other peers and it is the maintenance of
these conditions which have formed the
basis of all we considerations of no TC
at Columbia be the question of whether
to award or deny a degree credit for any
ROTC course will remain it with the
deans the faculties and the committee's
on instruction of the relevant school's
faculty appointments will be under
Columbia Columbia control and as well as
physical space and other resources so in
fact these are the institutional yeah
essentially this is what has been called
as a Princeton or MIT model and you know
we dug in our heels in 1969 we stopped
but nobody else did and the issue to
some degree has passed us by and the
Princeton MIT and other places have
maintained these programs and they work
there and it is on the basis of those
programs that were considering Thanks
thank you nice question
I'm Ted grasty and I'm spokesperson for
the Columbia Alliance for rotc which is
a support group for rotc i'm going to
branch off a little bit based on some of
the dialogue this morning because there
seemed to be issues on education on the
government on the military and I just
want to add some information that after
a 30-year association with military is
very factual first there are really two
stages in an officer's education the
first is what you see in the ROTC that
is the young second lieutenant or anson
it's very technical and it's socializing
you have to learn the culture at the
culture was mentioned before it is also
in the current ROTC programs heavily
infused with ethics and leadership
especially in the first two years of the
program the second phase is for what is
referred to as the commander or the
lieutenant colonel or Colonel rank or as
we ex-military people say the old fives
and the old sixes hey grades count that
is a whole different socialization and
intellectual process as evidenced by
thirty-four percent of active-duty
military officers have advanced degrees
nine percent of the american population
does and i can give you the references
if you need the services values critical
thinking yes there's a stage where the
new officer has to do procedures to some
extent by the book or people get hurt
not too dissimilar than a young doctor
on his first operation so the point i'd
like to address is the services value
education they value critical thinking
you should not stereotype based on your
observation of a war movie in a second
lieutenant thank you thank you very much
good observation next hello my name is
dr. bill drew excuse me dr. Mildred
Palmer I'm president of cinema verite
intl inc my doctorate is from Columbia
University and I worked all over the
world I was sent by the United States
government to work as an educational
consultant after perestroika and
in Siberia I think that in a perfect
world it would be wonderful if we didn't
have to have any wars or any armies but
I've been all over and I've seen it's a
highly imperfect world and it's
necessary to be prepared for that world
and so I personally think that our GIS
or veterans or whoever you want to call
it and I'm from the old school obviously
they deserve some kind of credit and
they're getting practically nothing I
have written an article published it
about the importance of having veterans
in the classroom I would like to see
more of that and I have a statement this
is a statement it's not a question but
if one of you wants to answer it fine
thank you very much I think we have time
for one more question and then I'll ask
each of the panelists to thank you and
I'll ask each of the panelists to to
spend 60 seconds saying whatever they
wish to say last question this is a very
brief question so maybe we'll have time
for their comment well maybe the
response will be long i hope it is it's
kind of a joint question for dr. health
and dr. Betts I just my name is jordan
by the way sorry i'm a second year super
student i would just like to ask the two
of you to attempt to sort of reconcile
two interesting observations that you
each made dr. health and your
observation that the military and the
Academy are two separate valid and
important institutions with very
different missions different different
different mandates and that those those
mandates are basically diametrically
opposed and then dr. Betts that that the
military is an instrument among many of
the federal government and then you made
the observation that of course the
federal government is deeply present on
columbia's campus so what I what I would
like to ask the two of you to do is to
sort of reconcile this challenge in
particularly dr. health and to address
the what I what I think is a fact that
the dr. Betts asserted and to try to
determine what is distinctive about rotc
that makes it more antithetical to the
Academy than both the federal government
that is rotc sir that is the military's
master and many other government
agencies who may or may not be equally
or less antithetical than the military
is to the Academy thanks professor bets
would you like to start and then we'll
just come down the panel for final
remarks or you can address this question
as well well I think David help man has
a point in the sense that as a practical
matter there aren't many precise
analogues to the RTC program as a
mechanism for facilitating the entry of
Columbia students into professions or
different lines of work and that it is a
formalized program that's different from
the way that students go from Colombia
to Goldman Sachs but it seems to me that
in effect Columbia does the same thing
to facilitate students opportunities in
other lines of work I mentioned the
business school the analog to the
business school would be a degree
program in military operations and
strategy which existed some universities
especially in Britain but not much in
the unit in the United States so I would
see that is the practical reason for
seeing a similarity even though in
strict organizational and institutional
terms there is indeed a difference Thank
You professor helfen
yeah my point keeps coming back to the
institutional arrangement that's what is
is the basis of my objection I have no
problem with Columbia students being
members of an ROTC program I certainly
have no problem with veterans being at
Columbia as students that I'm much in
favor of that and having started here in
general studies I think it's an
excellent way to facilitate their
re-entry into civilian life however we
do not while we accept money from the
government for research I do the
government does not say they own a piece
of my lab the business school accepts
money from Goldman Sachs but they don't
own a piece of the bit of the business
school and furthermore they don't
specify what curriculum should be done
what faculty should be teaching and
specify requirements for students that
are outside the requirements set by the
faculty who in my view as President
Eisenhower was corrected or the
University can I just mention those that
I think both Allen and I and most people
involved stipulate that in the afrotc
were to be reestablished the Columbia it
would not be under conditions where any
of those differences supplied in terms
of
that's fine curriculum and degree
requirements that the point of the
things of that sort in other words the
military would not own a piece of
Columbia professors over I've also been
heard the story many times and I'm told
that the faculty member who objected the
general we are the University of course
is about it it was it was is it a
regular so I've heard it from look in
many ways I mean the university is not a
democracy and public opinion doesn't
count up to put it very and I speak as
an old poster and the faculty I'll say
it out loud the faculty is ignorant and
I actually disturbed by the extent to
which the faculty faculty is not
involved in see I don't think that the
Senate is the is the sovereign
bottomless never the Faculty of the
server bots in this man so in that
respect we couldn't agree more and
actually the way in which president
faust at Harvard it seems has completely
wept over the faculty to make this deal
the text which is not yet public by the
way is it doesn't do credit to my cause
which is which has been put to bring
back ROTC well you know it takes two to
tango the fact is that there are
invested Betts knows a lot more about
this than I will ever know but there are
significant elements in quote in the
military that want nothing to do with us
on cultural grounds
and one of the one of the good things
the cultural Goods political goods that
you think would come out of the value of
what is mistakenly quote our DC
returning is that this kind of gap of
mutual incomprehension would be a lesson
and I think that's a social good for the
country the reason why I don't like the
idea of the phraseology of RTC returning
is that if rotc in any form would to be
set up here it would be on our terms on
the terms at the military projected in
1969 our Terms not their terms many of
the objection which I certainly share
simply don't apply there is a sense in
which ROTC here it would be in many ways
and extra-curricular activity no credit
no professorships the curriculum is in
our hands I don't deny for a moment that
our TC has unique aspects some of the
organizational ones I've addressed and I
don't deny for a moment that the
military is not equivalent to any other
kind of public service quite distinctive
in ways which we all have in mind but I
do think that it would not be the case
of the military owning a piece of this
University which is an opponent idea it
would be on our terms Thank You
professor Robbins you have the last word
I think the United States should have an
army I think we might need it one day in
self-defense and my father served under
Dwight Eisenhower and was decorated
there's something to be said about
Eisenhower's parting speech about the
military industrial complex in terms of
whether the military is just a tool of
civilian administration or not I mean
why so many dollars are going away from
other things and going into the military
I'm not sure tool quite quite does it
but okay self-defense there are no lines
of landing craft attacking the Jersey
Shore how much of what the United States
military has done can be conceived in
any plausible way as self-defense we
have gone out of our way with some
fairly outlandish reasons to seek out
people far away to fight with that is
what on the whole the United States
military has been doing it has not been
defending the United States on its
shores I don't think it's been defending
the United States at all and therefore I
have the kind of moral problem that I
was trying to express one more point
this speaks to the clash of missions and
cultures between the military in general
and Colombia the independence of mind
that I hope that we teach here the
independence of mind that I'm afraid
cannot really be a major part of the
military if indeed the military is as
dick bets with suggesting just a tool
that has to obey Washington how to say
this I admire Colin Powell a lot I think
Colin power Powell was a man of honor
and decency and if he had behaved in an
honorable way when he addressed the
United Nations he would probably have
been elected president but his culture
of socialization the ethic he had
learned about leadership was also an
ethic of obedience to orders and
therefore when the commander of chief
said lie to the United Nations and say
that their weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq that
what he said and he helped get us into
this war and I'm afraid that's exactly
how much latitude there is most of the
time for somebody who tries to exercise
independent thinking within the military
I want to thank all of our panelists the
Arnold Saltzman Institute for war and
peace studies and all of you for
attending this interesting discussion
thank you